south africa is seeing another wave of
anti-immigrant protests they are mainly
targeting foreigners from neighboring
countries who came to south africa
without papers the protests are driven
by a new movement called operation
dudula the doula means force out in the
zulu language and it's creating fear
amongst migrants in the country
i'm so much worried that it might come
to us
you know it's so painful that
we all africans and when i am here in
south africa i'm from zimbabwe in south
africa it's like i'm home
no matter where are you from as long as
you are with the people you are with
your family let's live together as
family you must learn to share love
they are killing us for what reason we
don't know they are taking everything
all
our money we didn't bring nothing them
they give us a job we take our job for
them we don't know what what what is
kind of people that can think like that
for more on the xenophobia in south
africa our adrian kresh report from one
of the anti-migrant protests in the city
of rastenberg
[Music]
we're angry and we are here to take care
of the foreigners this is what these
south africans sing in zulu as they
march through rustenburg the protest is
organized by a group called operation
dudula the group says it wants to rid
south africa of undocumented immigrants
[Music]
i am ready for any eventuality whether
foreigners think that they're going to
take south africa and make south african
second-class citizens in their own
country whether they do it by politics
whether they do it through bribery or
corruption or they do it by the gun we
are waiting at south africans because we
are conscious enough to now understand
what they're doing to our country and
with or without our political leaders we
the people will take the country forward
which means are justified in any means
possible to save my life and other south
africans lives where government can't
get to where law enforcement can't get
to we meet them halfway
members of operation doudula have been
accused of attacking foreigners during
previous protests some traders in
rustenberg pack up as the demonstrators
arrive but this time it remains common
protesters here say they are targeting
suspected criminals and drug traffickers
as well as businesses that are hiring
foreigners without documents in order to
pay them lower wages but many foreigners
living in south africa are saying that
operations like these are creating a
climate of fear and xenophobia
some 4 million immigrants live in south
africa according to government numbers
that's less than 10 of the population
but it's not known how many are here
without papers
many blame migrants for south africa's
problems of high unemployment the
soaring cost of living and a rise in
violent crime
researcher gottfried mulauzi says that's
wrong if
everybody was doing what they need to do
it could not be where we're at where we
blame
problems that are taking place in the
country to foreign migrants so this i
think it's issues that government has
dropped the ball and i think that's why
you see the rise of social movement in
the country it's a vote of no confidence
towards the political structure that is
in the community to him it's clear that
movements like operation dudula are
xenophobic vigilante groups if you speak
about issues of undocumented migrants
that is not the issue of a vigilante
group of a mob because that's what they
are that is the issue that the law
enforcement such as the police home
office department is taking up so it
does not give anybody a right as an
individual citizen to go and knock at
somebody's door and say i want to
enforce the law
[Applause]
[Music]
three weeks ago a mob killed a
zimbabwean gardener in johannesburg he
was beaten and burned to death by a
group wanting to control his papers at a
memorial service his family says they
had forgiven those responsible for his
killing but they still want the
government to take action
as a family we feel
certain and we're shocked by
the events after he had not done
anything wrong to anyone i don't want to
comment about operation pedula the only
thing that i will comment about is that
anyone who commits a crime should be
arrested and sent to prison where chris
criminals
belong
zimbabwe's ambassador was chased away by
mourners when he tried to address the
funeral many of south africa's migrants
come from zimbabwe fleeing poverty and a
shattered economy at home they feel
their own government isn't doing enough
to keep them safe in south africa
in situations like this there will
always be comments that will be met
the government of zimbabwe is doing what
it can
is engaging the south african government
in order to secure the safety of our
nationals in this country
the government of zimbabwe is also
presently
working on a program to support and
assist
they return to zimbabwe of those
zimbabwes who wish to go back
at the operation dudularelli and
rustenberg attendees continue to voice
their
frustration illegal immigrants
succeeding in life
while we continue to be poor while their
voices are loud the attendance here
shows that they don't represent all
south africans far fewer people came
than anticipated